hello miss coffeebean always wanted to
ask you how old are you are you old
enough to remember those times in
computer vision when autoencoders used
to be the big thing if you remember this
then you are indeed a very old person in
machine learning so be happy because
guess what auto encoders are fashionable
again in computer vision this paper
combines our favorite things
transformers masking auto-encoding and
self-supervision in a beautifully
written paper with a simple yet powerful
idea so welcome to this ai coffee break
where we will break down and explain the
most important contributions of this
paper miss coffee bean why did you bring
a sponsor oh because i was running out
of coffee beans and needed money to buy
some new ones but don't worry i would
never use you to make my coffee okay
then here we are this video was brought
to you by weights and biases if you
haven't heard of weights and biases then
surely you are living under a pile of
coffee beans with weights and biases you
can track your experiments and have
beautiful plots at the same time
reproduce your models and optimize hyper
parameters like a pro with sweeps say
goodbye to your good old uninformed grid
search and welcome their integrated
bayesian optimization and no you don't
have to understand this magic to use it
there are two things i find especially
impressive first you can integrate
weights and biases with just a few lines
of code like look at this
and secondly it's free for personal use
and it's also free for academic teams of
course the big players need paid plans
but if you are a student like me who
wants to stay organized even in the
advent of the paper deadline when all
your coffee beans are going crazy and
everything's a mess and irreproducible
from that chaotic excel spreadsheet you
use for tracking experiments
then you should give weights and biases
a try
great now let's talk about how and why
masked auto encoders are indeed scalable
vision learners hey miss coffee bean
take it slow like first what's an auto
encoder
auto encoders back in the day we're
reconstructing the input while being
constrained to encode the input into a
lower dimensional space then reconstruct
the input again enforced by an l2 loss a
simple distance metric between input and
output and because of the bottleneck in
the middle reducing the dimensionality
of the data the hidden space is a
compressed meaningfully packed and
efficiently packed version of the input
or in other words ideally the data
manifold is learned so ideally
semantically similar points are close to
each other in this space and
autoencoders worked well in computer
vision where the image space is
continuous but we're not as successful
in nlp one of the reasons is the
discrete nature of text even if we often
pretend that text isn't discrete by
representing words as vectors in word
embeddings the in betweenness of words
the interpolation of especially
contextless words is often not that
straightforward in the same sense it is
for the visual modality and this is
generating problems when trying to learn
the data manifold in the code space this
then further causes problems when
computing a continuous reconstruction
loss in what is naturally a discrete
space
but then everything changed with the
introduction of transformers doing
masked autoencoding which happened first
for nlp think about bert which is doing
what a must autoencoder does it corrupts
a portion of the data usually 15 of the
tokens and birth learns to predict the
missing content by classifying which of
all 30 000 or more tokens in the english
vocabulary could have been the right
word instead of the mask token and we
would like to do this auto encoding also
for visual data because think about it
this way a system that encodes data to
decode it again
not only has the advantage of
self-supervision that you do not need
labeled data because you just take the
input and reconstruct it but it also
learns more general representations of
that modality because self-supervision
means that the model is not allowed to
forget everything that is not relevant
for the label of that data sample as it
is the case in supervised learning but
needs to remember the essence of that
data point to reconstruct the entire
data sample only you see mask auto
encoding which since birth and its like
was made easy for nlp is now hard for
computer vision the authors highlight
three key differences between vision and
language the visual backbones used as
encoders for auto encoders we are not
ready yet in the era of cnns
convolutional based backbones rely on
the data regularity of image grids and
is not easy to mask things out without
introducing artifacts in the outputs of
the convolutions secondly vision and
language are very different in terms of
information density a word is already a
second order abstraction of the world
and compactly summarizes what otherwise
is represented in many pixels in images
also information in images is much more
smeared out because the neighborhood of
some pixels speak very much about the
masked out thing if we do not see the
eyes of a dog we still recognize the dog
whereas in language the context is not
that verbose and the crux of the
information is mostly in the mask token
what does this mean well while masking
out 15 percent of tokens in language is
already a lot masking out 15 of the
pixels is almost no corruption in images
and thirdly the decoding procedure is
more complicated for vision than for
language predicting missing words is
arguably easier because one predicts
relatively little things with high
semantic information for this just a
multi-layer perceptron or short mlp
suffices but when predicting pixels one
must regress these many values and while
caring about maintaining contextual
harmony between the many pixels one
pixel alone carries little semantic
information but the whole neighborhood
of pixels means a lot therefore it's not
straightforward to do this whole auto
encoding with transformers on images as
it is on text where the output is more
compressed or well it wasn't
straightforward until this paper
presented an elegant and simple solution
the recipe is
take the image and divide it into
non-overlapping patches this could be
something like 16 times 16 patches so
far we are exactly in the vit setting
and we will stay in the vit setting
where every patch is transformed into
one vector even if this is not
visualized right now in the video but
each patch here is a vector to
understand these prerequisites please
see our previous videos on the
swintransformer vit and dit if you're
not familiar with vision transformers in
general but now instead of taking all
these patch vectors as input it's random
masking time and by masking it's
actually meant removing let's say 75
of the original number of patches are
removed great then the authors take the
vit encoder and encode only these
remaining patches but why did they
remove the patches instead of just
masking them well because the authors
are using a transformer as an encoder
they could have taken all image tokens
including the masked out ones bearing
the value of the mask token but that
would blow up the sequence length this
compute time and memory because then
also masked tokens would need to be
processed in self-attention and then by
the feed forward layer in each
transformer block so because the authors
reduce the sequence length in the image
significantly by just removing 75
percent of the image tokens in the set
they now can use very large encoders by
increasing the parameter number in the
feed-forward networks greatly increasing
the capacity of the encoder but miss
coffeebean they are completely removing
intermediate patches like they never
were there before isn't that confusing
for the encoder no because these things
are almost removed like they were not
there before because the positional
embeddings still remember the fact that
this patch is from the upper part of the
image this other one from the second row
so there are many positions missing
there the the structure of the visual
modality is still encoded in the
positional embeddings so the encoder
with a small sequence length processes
the input and encodes it into the latent
space and the output of the encoder has
the same number of tokens as the input
has because the encoder is a transformer
and that's how usually transformers work
but after training it captures the image
semantics much better okay now it's time
for decoding because we are in an auto
encoder and this is where the mask
tokens are inserted again because now
when reconstructing the original image
the transformer decoder must follow the
transformer architecture one vector per
token in one vector per token out so
from the set of the ideally semantically
structured latent space tokens and mask
tokens the decoder which is also
transformer takes each token and
computes something else which is ideally
the original image patches or almost
because to reconstruct back from vectors
to the output image the authors again
use a linear projection to map the last
activations into the pixel space so that
the output of the model is an image and
the mean squared error can be computed
it's important to note that while the
encoder can be very big in terms of
number of parameters because its
sequence length was significantly
reduced by removing 75 of the tokens the
decoder operates on all patches also on
the mast ones this needs to be
lightweight
and this was the masked transformer
based auto encoder and look the
reconstructions look kind of blurry and
miss coffee bean thinks that one two
papers further this will be working for
high resolution too but you know the
reconstruction quality was not the goal
of this masked auto encoder anyway but
the learned representations over here
representations that are already rich
from this simple masked auto encoding
procedure and do not need contrastive
learning where it's hard to choose good
negative examples and needs image
similarities or complicated augmentation
methods like the competition uses such
as simclear moco dyno or bio these
representations can be used for
supervised tasks too like imagenet
classification or object detection or
semantic segmentation for more check out
the paper but what you need to know is
that for using the learned
representations for some other
supervised tasks possibly one just has
to remove the decoder fine tune some
more task specific layers which is easy
but it also needs to run the quite heavy
weight encoder on the unmasked image so
on the entire image
miss coffee bean how large are your gpus
again
just two more interesting takeaways and
we're done here miss coffee bean as
motivated in the beginning while 15
masking in textual data is noisy enough
for images masking more is better than
masking less and the masking ratio of 75
empirically has been shown by the
authors to work very well also random
masking is better than regular masking
which makes sense because the model
should have seen all possible
combinations of masks and positional
encodings or positions and if you want
to know even more about all this read
the paper and other similar papers and
while leaving do not forget to like and
subscribe
you